hello everyone and now we have we are
moving to the presentation from marty
um uh what zero right
yes one zero okay thank you and martin
is going to give a presentation about a
first step from sql to scalable etl and
martin is a data advocacy enthusiast and
is currently working as a data analyst
and apollo agriculture and marty you can
uh you can go ahead thank you
thank you for the introduction
so as i said i'm going to give a talk
about how you can move from ad hoc sql
to ask it about etl
and
uh also a very brief introduction about
myself my name is martin one zero i have
a background in mathematics and i am
currently working at that as a data
engineer at apollo agriculture which is
based in arabica
so i'm going to give you a background
about the company and why data is so
important to the company where i work so
the company started back in 2016 and
when it started this is the puzzle that
was presented to
our our founders they compared farming
uh
subsistence farming in africa and
commercial farming in u.s and they were
trying to look at
what amounts to
high dollars per acre and and these are
this is the financing farming inputs
advisory insurance and market access
and it was evident to them and as it is
on this side that the african farmer has
limited access to this and now this led
the ball of apollo agriculture
which comes in to finance the farmer uh
provide the farmer with farming inputs
advisory insurance and market access and
bundling all this together for
farmers in in rural kenya and giving
them a chance to increase their
amount they and per acre and make them
compete with farmers
uh fairly with farmers in kenya and
across 12
so how do we exactly do this so we have
set up a very
nice uh sales process that start up with
a farmer signing up so the farmer will
hear about apollo agriculture from
another farmer or from an agent or from
radio from any other marketing uh
channel we have set up and after they
sign up they will be on boarded into
apollo agriculture we collect here at
this point we will collect all the
information that we need we collect kyc
we will also collect our
information that we need for our credit
models and after that we
we do a credit decision on the farmer
and if the farmer is approved they go
ahead and pick up uh farming inputs from
a local shop
around them and then
after they pick up and after the farmers
have gone on and blood and we continue
to give them digital advice through
their phones and we help them set up
repayments repayment plans that so so
that it becomes easy for them to pay
for
to pay back their loan in the in the
long term
so given this sales process what does
that mean to the team the bi team that
is responsible to provide data to the
other departments in the company it puts
bi at the center of all
uh all departments in the company from
call center to field operations finance
logistics and collections
because all these departments are highly
highly data driven and they want to make
informed decisions so
bi serves all these
departments by providing
accurate uh data to help them make
informed decisions in their day-to-day
operations in the business
so therefore for for bi to start we had
to start somewhere and this is how we
started we started with using re-dash
which is a lightweight dashboarding tool
that allows you to write sql queries
against your database and
visualize them and also allows you to
use parameters so we started with
readers running on top of our production
database and at this point it was only
to see the ceo who was doing all the bi
work and it was really working uh the
data volumes at that point were uh in
the company were very small so it was
not hard for us to continue or to run
these queries on top of our production
database but as we continue to grow
we we then moved from running on top of
the production database to
creating a replica of the production
database and running queries on top of
that
which was still working and the switch
really improved performance and
the company continued growing as shown
on this chart this chart here shows how
the number of farmers
who are working with apollo have grown
from 2017 and at this point it was all
the all the bmw was done by our ceo and
then around uh as the growth continued
around
that quarter of 2018 we had our second
our first bi higher and the
second and blood in bed of 2020 and so
this growth
i uh
as shown on our next
our next slide uh so when we continue to
grow in the number of customers when we
continue to grow in the number of
engineers who are building features to
uh in our sales channel when we continue
to venture into new products and to go
into new territories
the setup we had for bi was having
starting to have problems with one speed
uh our dashboards were starting to
become very slow second accuracy our
dashboards have
started to become very error-prone it
was very easy to make a mistake and not
not singing
notice it and pad
on the onboarding process was very hard
because uh there was no proper
documentation so getting someone else
knew to join the team was very hard
so and expanding more on the problems
that we had one we found ourselves
writing long and very long long sql
queries as shown here where we have more
than 300 539 lines of sql and these are
nested cts and
sub queries so it was very hard very
hard for someone to come in and read
these queries or debug them also redash
allowed us to use uh
to do query composition where the
results of a query would be used as
as the
uh in in the form statement of another
query so queries would be referring to
other queries and this
got us to in in a realistic situation
where debugging was very hard we also
had we were also copy pasting code a lot
because we have
a piece of code that defines a business
logic that you want to use over and over
again so
if you copy paste that out in your
queries and you in the business logic
change like it should be then you have
to update all of them and first of all
even tracing them was a problem so these
are the problems that we started hitting
but the setup was still working for for
us but
so
we
took advanced step back and started
thinking about what we want to do to
improve this process and
when we wanted a better code review
process we wanted uh to be able to
uh have pears review code uh
in in the team also we wanted to have
proper documentation of the ipod so that
it was very easy to explain uh
the code we have and it was very easy
for someone else joining the team to be
able to go through the documentation and
actually understand what we are doing we
just wanted to have a version control
where we know when code changes and
white changed
then we wanted to
build testable and scalable models
and then we have we had gone through the
impossible modeling where we have our
fault table surrounded by dimensions and
we wanted to modern our data in this way
so that we can
we could improve our reporting in the
warehouse so
this being what we really wanted we
needed to make decisions on tools that
we want to get
for us to do this and
we had to choose a database and we went
for a very unusual choice for our
warehouse where we choose a postgres
warehouse and this was mainly because of
the fact that we were collecting gis
data which we could at that point we had
no other database
that was processing js that as good as
postgres was for us so we had to go with
postgres and going with postgres also
meant that we did not have to change the
sql syntax so we just moved our queries
from our bi tools into the warehouse
second we needed to know how data would
get there from all these different
sources from the production database and
other sources into the warehouse and we
chose stitch data so we wanted a
plug-and-play tool which had minimal
support from engineering and that's why
we went for stage data
we also wanted to know how we could
coordinate jobs and we went for gitlab
ci simply because it was very easy to
set up and also the fact that our code
lived in gitlab then it was so uh
seamless to to use gitlab ci
then the most important part for us was
how do we manage
the models how do we manage the
transformations in the warehouse
and we went for dbt and if i go
to more details on why we're in dvd like
i mentioned that we had these pieces of
business logic that was repetitive
across all several queries so dbt
allowed us to have that business logic
that
populates uh or other sql
so dbt allowed us to make that a model
and use it
and use it in other models so in it was
it was easy for us to update that
business logic should it have changed
then liberty has very excellent
documentation which was something we
wanted so that we could
make it so clear to anyone who
wanted to know what was happening in bi
or any other new any other person who
joined the team three uh we wanted to
leverage uh the fact that
dvd allows us to use ginger and python
macros
and then the bts works with russian
control and then
most importantly
dbt also allowed us to test our models
so that we could make sure that uh the
business
logic that has been said is not violated
so if i put all these together this is
what we now have uh on the left side we
have all the data sources from our
postgres production database to google
sheets and uh our course database the
course database and this is uh
replicated into the data warehouse using
stitch
so after
the tables are in the warehouse and we
normally call them the source tables
when they're in the warehouse then dbt
takes cover where it does
transformations
uh so
it does we we dbt we create models uh
which are simply sql statements that
create maths data maps in the warehouse
and again like conventions they are in
fact affecting them
fact tables and dimension tables and
then now all our database visualization
tools from uh redash to tableau and
other consumers such as data science
canal query or other can now run on top
of these data maps
so um putting this into practice this is
an example of an uh dbt model we have
called first tasks uh so
like like i said dbt allows us to use
ginger so it use allows us to use these
uh
references this ginger style of
using the source and the wrap where the
source means as a stable a table that
has been replicated into the warehouse
and that refers to another model so
another piece of sql that operator table
so you if you want to refer to it you
use this right method
so dbt determines the execution order of
these models such that if you run this
model then dpd needs to run the two
models that depend on
that this model depends on
so that this model runs so that ensures
that uh our data is always updated
and like i mentioned dbt has excellent
documentation so given this model called
fact task which refers to two source
tables and two other models then we're
able to see this dag file we in fact ask
us for tasks at the center and you can
see where it gets the data from from
these two sustainables and from these
two models where one of the models
refers to associable
so
with this dug
it's easy for you to debug so if you
want to make any changes or improvements
in fact tasks you're able to understand
where it's coming from and when it where
it's going so
when you do your changes you're able to
test them and make sure that uh
all the models that rely on the model
you are changing are actually running
and also the bt easily allows you to do
that so debugging is very easy improving
our code is very very easy
then
like i mentioned uh
dbt has excellent documentation and this
is an example of a tml file which has a
documentation about a model called fact
agent anims it allows you to have the
description of what that model does and
then it allows you to delete the columns
and have their name in the description
and tests on columns so for instance
here this column is called batch payment
entries id and
the test is that this column should be
not null and it should be unique
so
once dbt runs and tests the models and
all the models first you become
confident that the data you have in your
warehouse is accurate
it also allows us to do
custom tests like here we have this uh
custom
test unique
uh
where you
this column is nullable but if it's not
null the value needs to be unique so it
allows us it allows you to have such a
test
so these are what i was calling schema
tests and
this next line shows a cast of death
where um like i mentioned the source
uh the source ginger syntax means a
table that has been replicated in the
warehouse and the ref means that a model
that has been built in the warehouse and
so this is a custom test that looks at
them amount in the two models and
here uh in the last line each
it makes sure it makes sure that the two
amounts are the same so again this is a
business logic and
that that needs not to be violated so we
need to make sure that the amount that
comes in
the tables that are replicated in the
warehouse is the same amount that we'll
be giving out when we are doing uh when
we
we are doing our analysis so
this test allows us to be always
accurate
then like i mentioned dbt allows us to
write macros so we had a challenge where
we have
a set of columns so for instance let's
let's say payments
and we have a column called payment
total and we have three reasons for
payment so we have payment and release
on let's say payment reason a reason b
and reason c so we have payments total
and payment underscore a payment b and
payment c and the expectation is that
payments total is equal to payment a
plus permit b plus payment c but then
again probably later we will have
another reason for payment so we will
have pretty much d so we wanted a way
where we can uh
know
free hand or whether we can know all the
columns that starts with payment
planters or something and then as long
as it's not payments total if we add all
those columns they should adapt then in
total so we made this macro which takes
in
a table name and rejects expression and
it returns a list of columns that match
that rejects expression in that table so
dbt allows us to do that and then use
that uh list to iterate through and make
sure that
those uh thumbs or other all the
different reasons for payments add up to
the payment store so this allows us to
even scale in terms of the fact that if
we get many more payment reasons then we
will always be
doing the test correctly and we will
always be catching errors should there
be one
so another macro here um so
we we have indexes in the models that we
make in our database
our data warehouse and our postgres
requires our index to be unique so we
wanted to have a combination of
the runtime the column name the table
name
and
it was very hard for us or rather it was
very lengthy for us to repeat that over
and over again and when we were trying
to create more than one index in in a
table so we made this macro that
uh
given a list of columns it will be
creating uh
indexes on these columns are so and
down here below is uh we we see the
macro in use
where it takes in three columns and it
will create indexes on the three columns
so having said that and having done all
that what difference does it make so if
we compare what
uh
we had then and what we have now as you
can see now we we are able to move from
this long and long and nested
sql queries to very short and
straightforward queries running on top
of
or rather running on top of the maps we
have made in the data warehouse
mods which have proper documentation so
should you want to uh
get the documentation for this it's
easily available for you so this has
really improved our queries it has
improved our acquiring spirit has
improved our accuracy
so therefore what's next for us so
having done that we still continue to
consider ways in which we could improve
this
process so one uh we are as i mentioned
we are currently using github ci but we
are looking at other
workflow tools such as prefect and
airflow because uh right now we are also
doing some other transform data
transformations in python and we want a
tool that allows us to manage that
better and also to allow us but
to allow us better should we have
failures in our data pipelines
we also considering uh
another the data replication tool i
mentioned we are currently using stitch
we are considering to have intros such
as airbite
and this is mainly because of our gis
data
so we wanted to that better
replicates that data better so that we
can be able to do analytics even on our
gis data in the warehouse and then i as
i mentioned we are still using a
postgres warehouse and in the long term
we look into migrating to a more
columnar connected structure database or
that
will allow
our that will
be better for querying and for using as
a warehouse but for now we continue to
use pro postgres database which is
serving us sufficiently
and that makes the end of my talk unless
there are questions
thank you marty uh now the uh
floyd is open for questions and actually
there's one question in the chat
martin can use it it's about
the replicated table
tenner would like to know
whenever there is the replicated tables
in the architecture and what kind of
such architecture is usable
where we only have 10 records per second
transaction databases
yeah so um the replicated tables are
tables from all these other data
data sources so for instance in our case
the biggest is our production database
so where all the tables in the
production database are replicated into
the warehouse using speech and yes it's
possible for for for you to have
replicated
uh data where we have 10 records per
second but
the tools that are out there for
application allows you to set how the
frequency of how you want to replicate
and for us uh
we have set it at 30 minutes because
that code sounds the business right so
yes it's possible for you for you to
have that
okay on this another question about and
if there are good sources to learn query
languages
yeah so okay right now um
the query language we use is uh sql
structured school language and uh there
are very many sources out there
uh
one of the most common that is w3
schools which really has nice examples
and it's also very nice for someone who
is starting or if you are in any level
so you are able to see order to specify
what level
are you and you are able to get
challenges that will help you become
better in
in uh quoting languages so yes
okay let me see oh uh there's a question
if the uh if on the system you mentioned
um account is a cloud-based system
yes uh our so we have hosted our
warehouse in the cloud so is our
production database yes so they are all
hosted on the cloud
okay and there is a question from brian
give uh what's the most challenging part
when you are moving from ad hoc
so
in my opinion i believe it's making that
decision and saying actually i really
want to move i i want to get this talk
and also getting the right stack for you
so
the most challenging
part is the decision and getting the
right stack for the kind of uh data
needs that you have but once you get
over that then it's easy for you to
slowly transition from an ad hoc query
uh
to to having a scalable etl
okay i think this is the last question
we can cater before we move on to the
next presentation it's from morris um um
it's about if marty you would like to
you can you will start the journey again
building such a data pipeline what would
uh is there something you would do
differently from what you're doing right
now
uh if i was to do differently in right
now
so one i i would take some more time to
think about the kind of bit area house i
want to use uh i know there has been a
lot of changes between when we did uh
move to user postgres to what we
currently have right now
so
i would take some more time to think
about uh the data warehouse that i want
to move to
uh to
the
workflow management tools uh
that's another thing that i find very
key because it determines how frequently
you update your data so i would also
take some more time to
and also probably think about the future
and make sure that i get a tool that
will allow me to do what i want to do
now and what i might want to do in the
future
okay martin thank you very much again